[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima we are here
at famed choreographer Travis walls
shaping sound after the curtain show and
he's got a lot of famous dancer friends
in the audience including Derek Hough
Derek talked to me about his little
sister lands big upcoming wedding day
I mean how emotional are you gonna be on
that day big brother I'm excited I'm
excited you know it's my baby sister
getting married it's a special to have
all the whole family there we're gonna
have a great time we're there Rubina for
like a week so it seems like a week-long
event it's gonna be amazing I'm gonna
make a toast ripping a meteor um I think
I will be I think I'll be making a
little speech so yeah some surprises in
store there's always surprises my family
that aren't planned
so there's play of surprises last
question I got to ask you Julianne and
then Max and Peter are getting married
on the same day how are you guys gonna
make sure as a dancing cast that like
everybody gets celebrated extra parties
what do you think
I vote for extra party even I don't know
I don't know yeah different we have
different friends different friends in
different different groups
[Music]
you